le note sono anche molti ora ti prego
aiuti solita storia cosa grandissima
richiesta nuovo video con aghi il
pupazzo cattivo magnetico ecco qua a di
wadi lo vedete qua dietro oggi proveremo
un nuovo gioco con ai luoghi qua c'è
anche poppi la bambola se non avete
visto discorsi gameplay andate a vederli
poi dopo quella di solito oggi
giocheremo a nascondino con aki wak in
alcuni turni noi dovremo nascondersi da
chi vuol fare moto che non si trova
invece in altri turismi saremo noi a chi
vuoi che dovremo trovare gli altri
personaggi ed eliminarli lessate un bel
mimì assemblee te devi comodi pre di
poker iniziamo subito ecco dobbiamo solo
aspettare che inizi il prossimo turno
vede di commenti chi fa più paura poppi
la bambola oa di whiting secondo me
anche i luoghi
r quelle file di denti come gli squali
così non è infinito vitale nel frattempo
andato in giro a cercare
cimentare dentro alla casetta e dobbiamo
votare che gioco vogliamo trento si
apriranno le votazioni perché in questo
gioco si può giocare a nascondino non
solo con anche i luoghi e poppi ma anche
con altri personaggi paurosi c'è un
altro giocatore o che belli questi
capelli
oggi dobbiamo votare prima il luogo
l'ospedale scuola ospedale io voto la
scuola e ora dobbiamo votare il tipo di
gioco classico versione nightmare
juncker la
andiamo con il classico ok stiamo
iniziando eccoci qua lo shock killer
iniziamo come brigati stiamo nella
scuola dobbiamo scegliere un
nascondiglio prima che arrivi dei fossi
io mi nascondo
nome trappola per fortuna mia famiglia è
arrivato ma ti si è nascosta noi dove vi
sono nascosti e quindi che non tenga 86
che stai guardando il pavimento sono
la cattedra ei ma forse non è agguati il
killer in questo turno non mi sembra lui
dal lavoro si erano fittiamo 6 luglio ma
stai uscendo fuori voglio controllare
chi è
tutto pronto le monete da riusciamo
esploriamo diciamo qualcuno fa chi è che
tutti i giocatori si sono nascosti
qualche cosa ci fate qui
si presuppone ogni tipo una bomba
[Musica]
davanti aiuto sto scappando in una
palestra
eccomi qua sono nella palestra quindi
ecco ma che cos'è
nome offre uno dei morto hai guadagnato
10 punti o qualche consolazione ho
guadagnato dieci porte in gioco votare
prossima partita questa volta dobbiamo
nasconderci meglio speriamo che arrivi a
chi guardi non so perché si era quella
bambola inquietante perché ci sono vari
cattivi da cui bisogna nascondersi
allora questo lo diversi l'originale su
21 la fattoria all al film 58 eccoci qua
allora la maggior parte ha votato una
modalità classiche e penso che sia per
quello che appare quella bambina bambola
malefica dobbiamo scegliere nel prossimo
turno un'altra modalità poi chi è questo
ok
dopo arrivano loro ne avevi uscito
proprio ho
giocato ma uscita proprio davanti a un
mese un barile davanti a me non ci credo
la scelta come sua vittima è stranissimo
questo post sembra un labirinto già
presi due attentati
a centrare è uscita proprio da qui è
dove tutto buio
devo riuscire a sopravvivere per 3000
pasta
mista in seguito che cosa in mano un
coltello
si no
iniziamo la prossima partita
eccolo e le parole og ibrida ed nome
noto escono varie cose da votare random
volontà quindi vari personaggi vari
cattivi mettiamo questo hanno tutti
votato questo vediamo com'è ok forse
vuol dire che anche i luoghi ancora più
spietato e questo
siamo provare la posizione giocatori di
a di maghi e uguale che
fino a piazza con gli abbiamo solo 18
secondi sbrigatevi a tu dove sei anche
chi non è se sono le scatole ma lui non
è quando prova a scappare queste
innovazioni andiamo nella stanza
innovazione credo che sei qui dietro
unità
che no niente volevo spaventarlo
ma qua non si può entrare nel gioco lo
sta arrivando tutti qua ci siamo
nascosti io sono qua dietro e le scatole
questa volta dobbiamo riuscire a
sopravvivere
barca sulla tomba
perché non è odio maghi ma ci sia
arrivato qua dietro
e vediamo cosa fanno gli altri basta
cliccare su sex gate
ecco questa è la bambola ma l'etica come
si chiama si chiama scheri di hitler mi
sembra di aver visto si è un po strano
dove è nascosto compenso che adesso
prendere
non ha trovato
lo prende ma
eccoci un altro partita non capisco dove
siamo e abbiamo scelto luogo magazzino
attenzione così penso che prima di tutto
però meglio questa torcia sentono dei
rumori ma non si vede chi era di guardia
adesso forse mi sono nascosto bene di
alla trappola dove viene cotto tu mi
sono nascosta anche preso che tratta a
devo fare katherine ha fatto bene
pensavo di restare nascosto bene che
questa cosa vuol dire che mi ha visto e
credo di sì ho detto anche ai ceo non
salire sopra qui perché forse è meglio
sia spegne la luce però è perché sono
positivi di individui non vedo niente
no cos'ha fatto questo che ha preso
allora questa volta vi nascondo per
davvero sono nascosta dietro alla
cattedra nomi ma non la vediamo questa
volta non mi deve trovare vediamo io
invece ho scelto un altro approccio
scappare che cosa sono quindi anch'io
sono le moto non so forse è lei che si
fa illuminare i pro che rilascia a
trovarci
nola votate presente a scappare
no pret a londra riuscirò mai a vincere
questo gioco
prossime votazioni quando votiamo quando
siamo mai stati asylum ok dovrebbe
essere che cosa si può il manicomio
credo proprio di sì bene sarà molto
inquietante portiamo la modalità
classica e poi non vedo l'ora di
capitare anche io il killer ok
nascondiamoci
attento alle trappole è così da queste
scappando
le porte non ti aprono voi sto andando
di qua aiuto devo trovare una famiglia
velocemente allora vediamo queste porter
non è anche questa si apre questo forse
è il posto più inquietante di tutti se
non popolo anche io qua dietro
io posso dire sulle scale tutte le sere
qui dove ci sono anch'io siamo tutti
quanti io sono sulle scale sono entrata
in un'altra stanza la madre decisa dalla
voce mi sembra di nuovo quella della
bambina della bambola ma dov'era di
maghi fa nella spazzatura o che mi
ascolto parigi bing maps ora fa non mi
troverò sicuramente non ha scritto
benissimo forma del guasto propri verò
per la prima volta
il tempo sta per scadere in un solo
quarto finalmente vincerò io torno
vediamo quanti punti mida
sopravvissuto solo 33 casa e così siamo
di nuovo alla fabbrica di poppi ma non
sappiamo se il killer e aghi vaghi
perché è strano in questo gioco di
nascondere di rho blocks con i cattivi
il luogo in cui ti nascondi può essere
quella di un personaggio ma poi il
killer e quindi il cattivo è un altro io
non vedo l'ora di capitare io e che il
loro è andare a cercare gli altri tu ti
sei nascosti nuovo qua dietro nascosto
basta brutta e troppo biglia
fino a tutti
voglio dare da un'altra parte comunque
non era lì a chi guardi di nuovo era la
di l'opera bambola state eliminate un po
di persone anche tu
no
bravo
ma aiuto dobbiamo nascondere la mia
camera non ci sono come ci sei e perché
arrivi dopo lo abbiamo ancora 20 seconda
tratta arrivino tutti aspettano questo
scondo
quanto mancasse tumori ma che devo
trovare e vitale
così come faccio a eliminare le persone
mi trovo vicino arbasino se non fare a
meno di carne a dopo prenderemo
questo non riesco a rivelare tutto
un'ora di maggio si eliminano personaggi
luoghi e buono e fa nutre di uova o
eliminato un altro e ora andiamo a
cercare vitale dove sarà vitale
cerchiamolo che strano e per questo sta
cercando di fare
quanti giocatori mancano mancano ancora
due o tre sono rimasti in tre
devo subito a trovare vitale anche se un
ampio 3 come un po strano siete
tuttotreno vedo dei pallini rossi laggiù
dovete schermo è come dare si sta
sparando allontaniamo sì non offrì di
colpi eccoci a qualcuno fa prendiamolo
presa è
rimasto in due io e un altro dover diete
o sei da fuori berlusconi no hay fermo
maturi un atto under tivano ti tedesco
spararsi
prendiamo vitale non ti sto facendo
qualcosa
ei fermati detto che siete basteranno
vediamo no scappo l'erba dove la o
quando qui così poi ti posso sparare ma
sembra che guardi sempre per terra
colpito
sto cercando di prendere sei troppo
veloce
ora vi prendo tutto il 2 devo vincere a
fine ho preso una rimane solo vitale
esitare contro i bivacchi punto la
ragazza cina
no no è appreso non ci credo
aiutiamoci troviamo subito cambierò e
vitale tanto lui ora di dire nel gioco
azzardarti ha guadagnato lo guardo vedo
quanti ce ne sono allora 246 asi
personalità regionale più ma che in più
qua è molto più inquieta mi sono anche
vestito dalla di wight tappe
vediamo io mi aspetto
il killer sta arrivando ecco la
musichetta inquietanti
ma chi c'é qua sotto c'è unità
no no no no no tutti come me lo zero ma
non riesco più vicina a noi qua allora
vediamo se qualcuno in questa casetta
eccoli laggiù dove sono dove sono tutti
a manetta
capiamo è questa ed è anni del resto
no
non era già morta mi sembra il morto si
100 alberta ha a mio eliminati due si è
sentito
ma questa è la vita questa iacono porta
e lucignano migliore già ci credo
proprio ad entrare in questa casetta
che c'è qui potete solo per gli altri
giocatori
vedo le lucine sono tutti nascosti qui
chi è questa è la vita questo
noi possiamo solo torna no no io sono
portami vedere a ce ne sono tre persone
sono rimasto incastrato bene anche per
tetto non è chiamato a spot si può si
può entrare nelle trappole non ci credo
devo prendere un arma
qualcuno è rimasta incastrata
devo trovare un'arma ovvero posto
eliminare vediamo quanti sono rimaste
sono rimasti tre ancora dove sono
nascosti
cos'è questo rumore sono le porte che si
aprono forza è finito mancano due minuti
non riesco a trovarle dove saranno
nascosti
o nou camp
vedo che ci sono gli altri feriti sono
gli altri sono tutt ora non sono
bloccato
se
c'è molto da dire io sono già morta
quindi non dobbiamo
quella musichetta inquietante
che ho trovato qui
26 chanel perché non mi può scendere
anche a salami nota non lo devo prendere
vita morte vinciamo noi non lo so dove
sarà anita avendo delle lucine
fa queste trappole che cosa sono questi
manichini
pesante
che sta arrivando a chi
sceglie lucio
mancano mai la tomaia forse vinciamo
anzi dove siete
non ci crede solo così schiappa cosa che
si erano nascosti dietro la macchina
dietro la ma ormai non ti renderò
ho perso bene il prossimo puntiamo
playtime topi playtime
andremo nella fabbrica dei giocattoli di
poppi spero di sposare di nuovo
spero di altri maghi io penso che non
posso più essere agli ultimi anni
proviamo modalità nightmare non so come
sia sicuramente farà più paura dai
canoni rivediamoci
comunicativo a chi aspetta che
nascondano e poi eliminato 6 in più
modalità nightmare quindi vediamo come
sarà farà ancora più divertente ma
soprattutto dobbiamo trovare vitale io
mi nasconderò bene così non mi troverai
che pure questo chi è ei eliminiamo
subito questo perché fa paura dei
minimi dato quindi questa modalità
nightmare fare la differenza forse che
c'è più buio e tutti al buio sia dal
buio io della luce rossa così mi vedete
arrivare
ei
regista secondo me non mi troverai
questo dove siete
non ha nascosto su per bene veniamo ei
ma perché
ecco l'altro
premio è preda di tutti e non ad una
stupenda ta dove inseguirla quanti ne
rimangono ancora 24
se nessuno dove saranno a costo abitare
non lo so uscite fuori se ne avete il
coraggio
vedo un pallino rosso laggiù
ecco la sei presa cui tenevo anche
adesso ne mancano tre io sono nascosto
troppo bene non mi troverai mai potevo
trovare vitale devo stare attenta ai
pallini rossi
[Musica]
noi dopo sta accadendo
visto
qualcosa forse qua
[Musica]
scoperta di un sinistro moto
2008 lì c'è qualcun altro un altro non
si creda o no sono rimasto solo rata
sarà vitale e allora ti prendono
tutti fratte problema dovrà comprare una
pulitina prequel e io
le monetine che mi sto perdendo io
presenta la tua ora no no
di che non mi riesce a prendere la più
veloce
e tradizionali tutto prenderà finale fa
sol nascosto si sono nascosti ma ti vedo
da come ti scappa scappa
ma quante volte divento
d'arresto tondino con imovie è stato
troppo divertente per noi la sate un bel
mi piace e ora vi lasciamo quattro case
lire di cliccare per vedere inoltre
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite elena viviani ciao